okay as you probably know we do these
like whatever five in a row and I
believe in the last one you call that a
cow right yes what it is clearly a horse
I say clearly in that they say horse it
doesn't look like a horse actually looks
more like a cow but you said cow
yes yes I did and the fun thing is that
seeing how this is done ahead of time
God knows how many comments were in that
video is a go insane and now everyone's
gonna like totally doubt your
adventuretime streak red even though I
can I like I see you in the corner when
watching it's like quoting lines and
even their actions when they say some
words but because you've got cow and
horse romping at but I accept it punish
me freely I accept I made a mistake
something it's not just it they say
horse numerous times and I forgot to say
like what like everything a dozen times
yeah I think somebody died yeah
oh my mistake and I accept the
punishment and not only that you forgot
when it's time
heaven look at you disgust okay so this
is the eyes I just realize how much I
can't identify with this episode because
we've had this thing looking at us the
whole time it hasn't bothered us it at
all but it's I like this setup because I
know people that kind of go through this
where it's like if they're doing
something and somebody's watching like
they can't do it but particularly
sleeping like I guess if if they hear a
noise or a tiny some people are just
like sleepers and even just the idea of
someone watching them or something being
offered even it's not off just something
they can't explain you know it can keep
them up and this is simply a horse's
outside watching them and that's it and
the whole episode is them trying to get
rid of the horse and then it's revealed
it's the Ice King which
all these didn't see that coming best
reaction I think I've ever seen from him
in an episode so far
well when the horse bits out the eye
skin yep what I even say looks like what
the hell pretty much like your jaw but
like it was like you were like this
extremely shocked by it that the part
where I laughed the heart is well the
last line is really funny I love him
trying to sleep and smiley just say I'm
still not happy staying awhile smiling
but the the part where I laugh too hard
is like I really had to sort of stop
myself keep laughing is that you know
he's there he's saying he was spying and
Finn and Jake are trying to make a big
deal of this and I screams like I should
go yeah yeah whether he's folding up the
horse and Oh see you later and he climbs
down and he's walking out just whistling
also just behind
I just want think he really he just
really thought he could go home oh well
bye and it just was like a heavy little
tune and just just see that foot come
out hit him in the action music starts
it just it really killed it I love how
content he wasn't there but he just
really thought nothing was wrong once
again proving that he as he said and
this doesn't know what it's like to have
friends yeah and it's you do seem to
feel more more sorry for I've yet
obviously that's just the character the
one thing I did notice this time around
is as much as I love the Ice King I do
really like him I do start saying myself
I throw other villains that can come
back and then we got Marceline like
that's cool but it's kind of just those
two and even Marceline is not always
necessarily a villain it's or just
whether if she feels like being so I I
do sort of saying myself like you know
maybe water to more other villains
getting can at least make a comeback in
there I love to see ricardio again that
was the Ice King technically cos they're
like his heart or something oh yes I
it's just clear the writers love the Ice
King and I guess the people of the Ice
King - so I don't know they don't deny
people what they want to get
guess makes sense but it made much more
variety they do definitely focus on the
Ice King the most and there's very few
villains that actually kind of do come
back and usually it's very briefly it I
can understand us kind of suck III I
really like funny villains like I like
there's so many funny main characters
and heroes and stuff but it's like funny
villain just always really gets me and
I'm glad they have one as funny as the
Ice King but it's maybe a couple more
maybe does guter get more of a role oh
yeah okay does like that like the he'll
be cool um that and there is a very
serious vilem that actually appears okay
um you will see him he plays a major
role which is exciting
okay Kauai is it in the Caesars in the
next one I think it is the next keep
talking okay so trying to think what
else I can say and I pretty much said my
piece about this episode
um just uh yes it is in this one okay
cool um I'm all those people where it's
like when like wow how's the kids that
won't come I was like this is a toy this
is no you I'm not touching I'm like yeah
I'm not touching you
yeah so it's like it's not the same
thing with like you know I you know like
zombie like you know I'm gonna watch you
like yes okay that's actually doing
something though no but like it's the
same thing like just for me I'm no
really heavy sleeper like when it's time
to sleep I'm like okay I'm just dead yes
so but I I kind of get the idea when
people say like you know like I can't do
it or I can't because I feel like
something's watching me or the faucet
tripping or something oh no what was
those there was those commercials with
like the Swedish furniture guy you know
it was a Kia that's right and it was it
was this commercial where it's like this
little it's like a milk dispenser that
looks oddly enough like a cow it has
these big said eyes on it and it's there
while like this couple is making out and
keep zooming in on this cow and it keeps
playing to sad music and they just while
they're making out they're practically
making love and the well the knocks
calibre falls over it just shatters on
the floor milk flying everywhere and the
music goes so sad and it cuts to the
Swedish guy and he just says you have
feelings for this cow that's because
you're crazy it has no emotions it's not
alive and like that's it it's like IKEA
there really are they did another one
with the lamp but well ok when I saw the
commercial I didn't know what I was
supposed to get because I'm like what
it's just a little cow thing so one and
you're supposed to make an emotional
connection to it and I didn't catch on
so I think it's the same thing like my
horse was looking at me I wouldn't notes
that that was what we've learned today
boys and girls my loyalty to you have
gone down okay IKEA made some good
commercials back then okay and that that
was at least one of them here's another
one with a lamp betray for another lamp
and he's like you crazy
and I laughed we have to keep doing
these what the save ways no the B Logs
with you know your IKEA I mean if you
just come in and do a segue each time
I'll be fine I can sit here and talk the
whole time then you just come in and be
like you know but so fifty and then walk
out I'm fine with that
we could try that next time okay that
may work okay hmm at least you would not
have to confuse it how horse with a cow
I run that joke you're doing to me
because I have a good Selfridge on that
one
you trying to mock me and the universe
says no you know why because you're
talking about Ikea what set things out
of thousand people talk about Kia you
know let's talk about his damn episode
okay I promise it myself what do you
have on this one um no being with
someone that can't sleep if you're
staring at them because I have jokingly
done that to my wife and she has trouble
actually getting to sleep knowing full
all I'm looking
it makes me definitely laugh when I see
a horse just staring into the window and
then when you find out that it is in
fact the ice king and he's so sad and
pathetic about it he's like Mercy's
totally condemning all whatever next
time it's an event later he's just like
I just want to know what it's like to be
happy to have friends it's like wow
that's really friggin depressing um I
did like how they dress up the horse as
a bunny and they try to lure the birds
in to take him away
that was fun especially when they start
pecking them on the head my wife I
thought I had a better joke on this one
because if they come they land on the
horse and they start pecking as she says
where they're just gonna take Finn and
Jake I thought it would be a little
favor
I see I would have felt that would have
been way too predictable I guess but
it's it's nothing would have been
funnier than what not that what we got
was bad I don't know maybe that's why
your jokes are getting screwed up you're
mocking the show maybe it may be I'm
this is why I'm not writing for
adventure time because I'm too
predictable and every time gods are
upset but I didn't confuse a horse for a
cow at least even though they said it
like a couple dozen times
couple dozen maybe even five follower
five six dozen yeah I'm fully where I
made the mistake so you're going to hell
and nato's fear nightosphere yes and
bananas bananas I'm a banana and wait
wait did you say something about bananas
in this one like there was something
making you look back out something no
it's a later episode but specs with what
you just said now the Adventure Time
God's love me even though I screwed up
you are a banana